como a senhora é um caso com cópia para
o lado pessoal de quem fala é o dark
tudo muito bem vindos a mais de um dna
mostraria que uma coisa é fazer um look
muito mas muito bom hoje vou gravar o
chão e lavar méxico tem nenhum problema
eu treinar aqui pela casa eo para que
todo o pessoal saiu de casa toda a
sessão de uma pessoa uma pessoa tá em
casa quero deixar claro aqui espero que
não
a única pessoa que ficar em casa para
além de mim é o cabo e jogar no chão e
lavar com uma pessoa é um pouco chato né
mas eu vou fazer uma coisa que enfrentou
hoje eu vou tentar evitar o caso do
curso ela porque está sempre
constantemente rodovia a posição é
lavável isso é muito irritante mesmo e
vamos ver seus pais sentado exatamente
só vamos tentar atingir uma meta de
sainha online não foi nem um pouco nem
100 já começa a se pouco vamos bater a
meta dos tachos e acabou por 33 mil por
que eu não tenha me mostrou nos 300 mil
e r 300 mil likes neste vídeo rock só
levantou o primeiro passo que é cuidar
do caso e eu vou cruzar com o chão e
lavar que podia ouvir o que pergunta
cadê o brasil
chamava 54 34 34 no total a dormir 3 525
43 54 35
a primeira ocorrência no 4 445 ainda
lava dentro do quarto caso de lama 5
está na hora do almoço e o caso
provavelmente partido para a 1ª à 5ª
linha e eu vou ficar aqui à espera dela
tem um tiro e sem elencar aqui na
rocinha que você deixar de lado vamos
ver o que vai acontecer agora não mais
432 meu carro que eu amava
o chão é o céu ela não não
[Música]
a cozinha lava 54 toda lava caso o
mercado não gosto de dizer 05 puxar
lavadora 21 23 21 x 3 232
o osso foi uma vacada ano
com isso ela lava por fora
a costura de cobertura da próxima vez
[Aplausos]
não pôde